what's the best programming language to
learn
if you're interested in machine learning
i would say python just because it's the
easiest one to learn
uh and also a lot of like programming
in machine learning happens in python so
it'll if you don't know any other
programming language python is actually
going to get you a long way
yeah it seems like sort of uh it's a
toss-up question because it seems like
python is so much dominating the space
now
but i wonder if there's an interesting
alternative obviously there's like swift
and
there's a lot of interesting
alternatives popping up even javascript
so i i or are
more like for the data science
applications but it seems like python
more and more is actually being used to
teach like introduction to programming
at universities
so it just combines everything very
nicely
you